[Aplausos]
con todo a por las elecciones de medio
término el presidente de Estados Unidos
dio un discurso de campaña donde dejó de
lado la economía la principal
preocupación de los ciudadanos para
plantear la votación como una cuestión
de vida o muerte algún llamado a todos
los estadounidenses independientemente
del partido para que se enfrenten a este
momento de importancia nacional y
generacional debemos votar Sabiendo lo
que está en juego y no solo la política
del momento sino las instituciones que
nos ha mantenido Unidos mientras
buscábamos una Unión más perfecta esto
también está en juego
recurrió su antecesor Donald Trump e
hizo referencia a la estrategia del ex
presidente tras las elecciones
presidenciales que acabó desembocando en
el asalto al Capitolio
sabes la democracia estadounidense está
bajo ataque porque el expresidente
Derrotado de Estados Unidos se negó a
aceptar los resultados de las elecciones
de 2020 se niega a aceptar la voluntad
del pueblo se niega a aceptar el hecho
de que perdió
una violencia que relacionó con la que
vivió el marido de la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes Nancy pelosi
cuando un asaltante la buscó para
romperle las rodillas
el agresor trató de tomar Apple como
rehén lo despertó y quiso atarlo el
agresor terminó usando un martillo para
aplastar el cráneo de Paul
afortunadamente por la gracia de Dios
por sobrevivió
la idea había limitado sus apariciones
debido a su baja popularidad pero sus
intervenciones van a aumentar en esta
última semana de campaña donde los
estadounidenses renovarán la cámara de
representantes un tercio del senado 36
gobernaciones y otros cargos estatales y
locales